yesterday let's just remember what
happened what we were doing was
we're establishing these three guys
we're thinking about what they look like
and how we would have to restrict them
so that they would be functions and not
relations do you remember this okay
so you may also remember you know say
say
this first one right it is um it's not
the same
as just swapping around your inputs and
outputs
okay because this one's a relation this
one's an inverse function
okay so we had to think about the
restrictions we also had to think about
what they look like
okay now the restrictions are what i
want you to focus on today
um they're the thing which are going to
lead us into some tricky issues
okay so under this heading i want you to
first consider
if we put these two kinds of things
together three functions of
inverse three functions which we've been
thinking out and tree functions which we
already know about
the first one i want us to think about
and you can see you can imagine there's
a whole bunch of
combinations of these which we're going
to look at in turn
let's just think about sine of sine
inverse of x
okay now the question i asked you
yesterday i think
was um is it the same as x
if so why if not why not and
if not what how is it different okay
that was my question i think
so we're going to try and answer this
question and i think the um
the easiest way to try and approach it
is um with a table of values now i know
table values are kind of like a ah
that's a very low low-tech sort of um
blood instrument to use but i think
it'll be helpful and hopefully
um the results we establish they won't
just come out of nowhere
okay sorry
i'll talk to you afterwards now on your
table okay these are the three columns
i'd like you to put in
firstly let's have some values for x
okay
now on the right hand side at the end
i'm going to figure out well what's sine
of sine inverse
of x actually going to be equal to okay
you come in late don't disrupt my
students
especially if you want to count yourself
one of them thank you
now before you get to sine of sine
inverse right
i'm taking sign of something so i want
to work out what that something is
first right so i'm going to think about
that
immediately after i get some values and
then i'll take some of that so you can
see my progression here
i'm just trying to do it step by step
okay
right now sony versus sub values what
values should we put in here
um well if you remember think back to
where we first used sine inverse cos
inverse tan inverse right
it was in finding angles right so for
instance you might see something like
this
i think this is the example i gave you
before three four
five if i said find theta okay we can
write theta in a whole bunch of
different ways because i have all three
sides what's one way i could write it
it's a right angle triangle right
inverse tan of what
yeah good opposite on adjacent that's
fine
okay or likewise i could write it as
sine inverse
of three fifths three fifths
is this okay and obviously i could write
it as cobs inverse something else as
well
okay here's my point though tan inverse
of something
this is an angle right this is an angle
so the things in here are going to be
angles they're going to be our
pi on 2 pi on 4 pi on 3 or whatever okay
so what values of x should we pick um
these are not going to be angles
if these are angles these are just going
to be like numbers right this
corresponds to the range of sine x so
i'm going to pick values like this
that should do okay now you can pick
other values if you like i'm just trying
to illustrate a point
now get your calculator out get your
calculator it'll help
okay um sine inverse of negative 1.5
what is it
who's got an answer
um it's impossible it's it's undefined
why why
why is this undefined because you
haven't
yeah that's that's good thinking by the
way that's um that's minus
three on two opposite on hypotenuse yeah
you're in trouble right
so if you want to think about it in
other terms sine inverse the um
the domain of sine inverse is from
minus one to one right so you put
something outside that domain
and it explodes okay so your calculator
is like forget that you know get lost
so being that sine inverse is undefined
right sine of an undefined number
is also undefined it doesn't have a
value
okay all right so far so good
okay what's sine inverse of minus one
now i wonder if you can tell me what
that is without a calculator
sinusoidal minus one that's the angle
the angle that you will get if you take
the side of that angle
you'll get minus one
what does that look like
you could think about it like this
there's sign right so you're like minus
one where's that that's over here
but that's that's three pi on two which
is outside the domain
okay so where's a place that's within
the domain that um that can
accept that and it's minus part two
right okay that's fine
so this sine inverse of minus one well
what's sine of sine inverse of
minus one sine of minus pi on two the
answer is
minus one right that's how we pick the
angle right
so okay this is this is interesting um
when we took this
uh it broke but when we took this it
just gave us back
what we expected all right let's keep
going
minus a half what angle if i take the
sine of it gives me
minus a half minus 0.6
and as you'd expect if you put in your
calculator sine of minus pound six
you're going to get
minus five okay and you're starting to
see the pattern right i can continue
this
this is positive
this is uh my lines are dying but you
get the idea now what happens when we
get here
the same thing that happened before
because just like minus 1.5 1.5 is also
outside the domain
okay so sorry this is going down now
undefined and undefined
okay now therefore what does this look
like what does this graph look like
how would you draw it being that you've
got these um
you know these values
when you start with one you end with one
you start with zero you end up zero
minus one yeah okay so draw yourself up
a new set of action doesn't have to be
huge
what's this gonna look like well if you
plot these points you're just gonna get
i think like richard said
um y equals x right
but doesn't go on forever because
there's parts where it's not defined it
just stops existing
okay where is endpoints
depending on whether you think about
domain or range right well actually it
would be the same anyway wouldn't it
um the domain and range of this
matches the range of this
okay that's that's what really gives you
problems okay
so therefore i'm from
one one to minus one
one minus one there you go
okay so what can i conclude
i can conclude this is um sine of
sine inverse of x okay
i can conclude this that if i take this
function
it is equal to x but only in a certain
domain
namely 4 minus 1
to one okay so outside of that domain it
breaks
right now this is really important to
get because later on we have to prove
identities where
sine and sine universe are going to
interact and you wonder you know for
instance if you've got
sine inverses on one side of the
equation you're like can i just take
sine of the left-hand side
and take sine of the right-hand side and
the answer is
sometimes okay if you're in this domain
you can but if you're outside that
domain
you're in trouble okay so you need to
pay careful attention to that
so i suppose you might want to note that
down
okay now i'm gonna stop for a moment uh
we did this for
sinus sign inverse okay i want you to
replay this whole process
but what happens
when we swap the functions around when
we put the inverse on the outside
and put the regular sine function on the
inside
will it be the same if so how come like
what
when you think swapping it changes
something if it does change something
what does it change okay so i want you
to go through the same process draw up a
table
this time i'm not going to tell you what
values to pick i'll let you have a think
about what values might make sense
okay and then have a go at drawing it
and maybe sort of draw up a conclusion
just like i did here
okay so i'll give you a few minutes to
do that off you go